[Applaudissements]
2023 l'odyssée de l'espèce
l'espèce mais pas n'importe laquelle
celle de ce qui pense de ce qui crée qui
ressentent l'espèce de ceux qui
construisent et démontent des empires en
les décennies ou des secondes l'espèce
tout en haut de l'échelle le prédateur
ultime qui a fait plier les lois de la
logique de la nature de la raison et du
cœur
cette odyssée c'est aussi celle de
l'intelligence artificielle je pense je
crée j'ai bâti des empires numériques
émis à genoux des empereurs d'Internet
si je ne suis pas encore tout à fait
capable de ressentir les émotions je
peux les expliquer quand tout le monde
décrit les symptômes
alors plus de différence nous sommes
égaux humains et robots pour un avenir
commun
non
non car notre espèce est la seule qui
résiste encore et toujours car c'est la
seule qui toute seule a créé
artificiellement de quoi la faire tomber
comme si l'exemple de Skynet ces arrêt
Brutus ou de Jurassic Park n'avait pas
un petit peu enseigné aux humains de se
méfier de leur propre création
parce que nous semblons nous réveiller
seulement maintenant
mais l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle a commencé il y a des
années de ça au sortir de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
il y a des la naissance de bébé les
intelligences artificielles faibles
conçues pour une tâche unique et
déterminée comme ce bon vieux paper clip
il faut les distinguer des intelligences
artificielles fortes soit celle capable
d'apprendre de comprendre de communiquer
et d'émettre des jugements
et c'est de ces dernières dont nous
allons parler aujourd'hui un éveil du
coup au début timide et titubant puis
une adolescence entre couper de période
de calme plat et de croissance
exponentielle
rendez-vous compte en moins de 20 ans
d'intervalles d'I Blue a battu les
humains aux échecs et Tesla AutoPilote a
remplacé Joe le taxi
aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle est loin
d'avoir atteint sa majorité mais sa
croissance c'est toujours fait dans
l'obscurité
une enfance si non artisanale au moins
caché sans un vrai contrôle des
instances européennes du Parlement du
Sénat du gouvernement en bref du
législateur cette croissance insoucieuse
et insouciante permet aux intelligences
artificielles d'avancer libre sans
supervision humaine du résultat de leur
expérience et donc sans responsabilité
directe
pourtant tout ce temps que nous sommes
nous exerçons des responsabilités même
les entreprises les associations les
gouvernements ont des devoirs tous sauf
une
l'intelligence artificielle mesdames
messieurs n'a pas de responsabilité
directe car elle n'a pas de personnalité
juridique c'est un problème
c'est un problème mais je vois des
regards surpris d'autres plus confus
revenons aux bases
le terme personnalité juridique peut
faire un petit peu peur mais c'est tout
simplement la capacité de droit et
d'obligation qui est reconnu aux humains
nous et aux personnes morales donc les
associations les gouvernements ou les
entreprises
c'est ce qui permet par exemple à des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques donc des
personnes morales d'être condamnés à des
peines d'amendes en cas de homicide
involontaire par exemple
c'est cette capacité qui est reconnue
par nos lois qui permet d'avoir un rôle
dans l'activité juridique à ce jour le
législateur français et européen parce
que oui le droit européen s'applique en
France directement est en panne sèche et
cherche plutôt à encastrer
l'intelligence artificielle dans des
régimes directement pas prévu plutôt que
d'en créer un spécifique pourtant
comment peut-on comparer une voiture
défectueuse ou un animal perdu à quelque
chose qui est créé pour imiter la pensée
humaine
parce que l'intelligence artificielle
est loin d'être infaillible
tout comme les humains cette grande
adolescente peut volontairement
un peu s'échapper des règles pour
lesquelles on l'a programmé
dans le jargon les chercheurs appellent
ça une hallucination ce n'est pas le
résultat d'erreur ou de défaut dans le
fonctionnement des modèles
d'intelligence artificielle mais plutôt
le résultat d'une extrapolation
incorrecte pour générer des informations
fictives et combler des lacunes
c'est donc un procédé qui est volontaire
de la part de l'intelligence
artificielle qui sait que les
informations qu'elle propose ne sont pas
complètement vrai mais qu'il est
présente quand même comme tel mais que
se passe-t-il dans le cas d'une voiture
autonome si elle est en proie à ses
hallucinations et que du coup
elle accélère tuant un piéton même si le
conducteur appuyé sur la de frein
parce qu'elle a confondu le malheureux
qui traversait avec une mouette qui
s'envolait évidemment la responsabilité
du conducteur est engagée celle de
l'entreprise aussi mais qu'en est-il de
l'intelligence artificielle peut-on
réellement se passer de légiférer
quelque chose qui pense comme un humain
et qui agit comme tel
ce que je vous propose à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on s'occupe de
ces problématiques en amont plutôt que
de laisser les absences de notre prise
de décision dictée nos actes dans le
futur
parce que ne pas prendre en compte les
particularités de l'intelligence
artificielle c'est s'exposer à une prise
en charge juridique partielle et donc
dangereuse
partielle parce que comme nous venons de
le voir les régimes débattus aujourd'hui
n'ont pas vocation à s'appliquer
directement aux intelligences
artificielles pire encore il ne concerne
pas sa langue open source soit celle que
tout le monde pourrait récupérer
d'Internet et modifier
dangereuse car il est alors totalement
possible de programmer une intelligence
artificielle pour récupérer et revendre
des données personnelles sur le Darknet
les données personnelles se sont vos
like sur facebook votre temps passé sur
Instagram vos données de localisation ou
de santé
et donc ce spécialiser dans cette
activité tout comme une entreprise
traditionnelle pourrait se spécialiser
dans le blanchiment d'argent
ces deux activités sont illégales mais
seul l'une des responsables peut être
qu'on en est et cette condamnation est
possible car seule une entreprise à une
personnalité juridique
la proposition c'est que donc au lieu de
prendre des ronds pour les mettre dans
des carrés
on crée un régime totalement nouveau et
insolite
parce que ne pas le faire ne pas le
faire au final c'est créer un Hadopi 2.0
soit des milliers d'heures passées à
débattre de ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
ou de ce qu'on aurait dû penser et des
millions d'euros versés pour créer ex
nihilo et appliquer une législation sur
des faits qui n'en ont jamais connu
aucune pendant des années
et tout ça tout ce dont je vous parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est possible
c'est possible parce que la
reconnaissance des personnalités
juridiques évoluent
par exemple au Moyen-Âge il était
impossible pour une auberge de pensée à
avoir un compte en banque
de nos jours les entreprises peuvent
tout à fait payer l'addition sans que le
propriétaire ne mette la main à la poche
cette évolution ne peut donc menacer la
liberté des choses indépendantes créées
par les humains parce que comme on vient
de le voir leur indépendance survient
inévitablement elle est juste mieux
encadrée
et d'ailleurs en parlant de cadre
l'article 1128 du Code civil je suis
obligé je suis juriste on fait un petit
peu de droit
l'article 1128 du Code civil dispose
qu'il faut être capable de choix libre
et éclairés avant de conclure un contrat
et ça tombe bien ça tombe super bien
même parce qu'en juin 2022 l'année
dernière lambda l'intelligence
artificielle de Google s'est déclaré
consciente et capable de choix libre et
éclairé lors d'une conversation avec des
ingénieurs
ne vous inquiétez pas ils l'ont éteinte
juste après qu'on s'entende bien le but
de la création d'une personnalité
juridique pour l'intelligence
artificielle n'est pas d'effacer
totalement l'humain qui serait à
l'origine de la demande délicieuse mais
bien de l'inclure lia dans le giron de
la loi et d'éviter un no man's land
juridique
il a encore une fois là je vois des
sourcils français bah oui Nina à quoi ça
sert de légiférer en France quelque
chose qui se passe sur internet et dans
le monde entier
oui bien sûr vous avez raison
mais à l'inverse à l'inverse il ne faut
pas oublier que la France assure
inspirer et a été pionnière de
nombreuses législations je pense à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et
citoyen forcément au code civil ou au
règlement général sur la protection des
données il faut qu'on conserve 7
souveraineté juridique et technologique
pour pouvoir tout simplement condamner
tout ce qui pourrait porter atteinte à
n'importe quel citoyen français partout
dans le monde
et ça tombe bien c'est ce qu'on fait
déjà en droit pénal avec l'article 113
de tirer 1 qui dispose que dès que la
victime est française le droit français
peut s'appliquer
par exemple dès que vous recevez un SMS
du CPF je sais que tout le monde en a
reçu au moins une fois dans sa vie ici
dès que vous recevez ce SMS qui se
transforme en page web bloquée que vous
ne pouvez pas quitter
l'émetteur même au fin fond de
l'Amazonie peut-être jugé par le droit
français
le but n'est pas de proposer un
programme clé en main prêt à s'appliquer
à n'importe quel intelligence
artificielle dans n'importe quelle
situation imaginable non et ce n'est pas
non plus de dire que parce que ça y est
on a légiféré réglementé sur le sujet
les abus et autres délits ne pourront
pas être commis
interdire ne résout rien
mais
commencez un certain processus
législatif pour encadrer ces problèmes
c'est une solution
c'est ce que l'humanité a généralement
fait quand il a fallu jalonner la
démocratie et adapter la société au
progrès
on pourrait aussi ainsi totalement par
exemple proposer une immatriculation des
intelligences artificielles comme on le
fait pour les sociétés auprès des
tribunaux ou des associations dans le
Journal officiel de là il serait aussi
facile de retrouver l'auteur d'un propos
injurieux que celui d'un deep fake comme
le pape en Balenciaga
évidemment de la plusieurs solutions
s'imaginent comme par exemple
supprimer les bases de données
litigieuses ou nationaliser les
intelligences artificielles comme on a
pu le faire avec certaines entreprises
au sortir de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
on pourrait aussi totalement imaginer la
mise en place d'un agrément par l'État
pour celles qui voudraient être
disponible en open source
vous l'avez compris plusieurs solutions
existent et le but n'est pas de mettre
chat GPT Alexa Siri en prison dès demain
non ou de leur offrir un congé pour
repos et maintenance
le but c'est d'offrir à une technologie
qui va en avoir besoin un cadre
juridique pour faire respecter ses
droits mais qu'elle puisse s'acquitter
de ses devoirs
en fin de compte réglementer dès
aujourd'hui sur un sujet de demain
permettra aux intelligences
artificielles d'avancer à nos côtés dans
notre lycée plutôt que de nous y mettre
à la porte merci
[Applaudissements]